taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to them hey Tasties welcome to t-a-s-t-e
buds we're just here talking about uh we
got a lot to recover yeah but first and
foremost the the clip of uh
of uh hey babe that just there's a clip
of hey babes that went out today so when
you're seeing this maybe three days ago
went out
Chris was talking about basically
I guess curbing some amenities in his
life and he's dressed literally like
Tony Rock he's in a full he's in a full
Sergio takini I mean literally he looks
like he got out of a time machine from
1987. it's crazy
and he was he was talking about a
practice he wants to put in place where
he I guess denies himself some amenities
so that it makes him appreciate those
amenities more is that the more a piece
like is that the more well-rounded way
to say what he was trying to say yeah he
said he feels he said he's recognizing
how blessed he is in life and he wants
to practice poverty two days a week in
order to continue to appreciate what it
is he has
and then he said like for example which
is first of all just practicing poverty
is so funny practicing poverty is that's
like that's like a new docu series with
him yeah practicing poverty and it's
only something that rich people do
because they feel bad
the privilege to practice poverty yeah
yeah yeah it's uh so so that was coming
from a good place I get what he of
course of course he's just saying he's
gonna make
convenient as they can be so that he he
he always appreciates what he has and he
yeah he very earnestly described poverty
as taking the ferry or the subway
instead of a pork driver yeah we're
getting instead of getting car or God
forbid saying in coach Clash on an
airplane right and you happen to be
outside the door I was I was when you
Cramer it in here it was the funniest
thing I've ever seen in my life so
here's what happened I was in the other
room you had to catch your ear I'll tell
you I was in the other room we had
recorded
and uh and right after and then it's
this is so there's a chain of events
here we had recorded we had just
finished recording our episode that is
not up yet the one that I'm referring to
is not up yet
it doesn't get crazy but it got a little
heated towards the end and we we started
kind of getting under each other's skin
a little bit not me and I know not yet I
know but I was it was it was we we
were pushed yeah let's put them and uh
and um but but literally is what we we
of course of course of course absolutely
uh I will I will fully admit you are
much better with a roll off the back
than I am I I'm not great at so
sometimes I don't think it'll hit me the
wrong way and it'll just
I'm like twitching you know what I mean
you know when we say these things right
it's like not my belief it's just
something that I know will ring funny or
something that maybe might be partially
true or something that I know you'll
laugh at because I'm just explaining
because because I was I had this thought
because I think that like because people
have been with us some from day one some
of them right and you know
out of the pie chart of our podcast is
probably a a decent slice like ten
percent where we was we really are
arguing like like
we there's a different energy when two
people are really arguing now you really
argue but we really argue about the
foods but sometimes we will have a
disagreement oh the one thing will lead
to another snowball and we end up
arguing and it's like I wonder like and
some people love it but I for me if I
was listening I'd be like
it's like your parents fight like I just
I just I don't know if I don't know if I
would be like oh this is every time like
this is interesting and entertaining to
me like or what happens is when you see
two people get intense right you you
naturally have a side right and then I
think you inadvertently or
subconsciously begin to resent the other
person in the argument right so I think
that there's temporary resentment to
some of us when me and you get into a
heated argument and people latch on to
that yes at the end of the day we're
leaning into this and we're we're doing
it on purpose and really nothing you
know we don't we don't leave here like
that no no of course but I do I do
Wonder like sometimes because there's
good arguing and then there's like
arguing like Jesus Christ and listen
this is getting me stressed out there's
only been two times where I was like
it was stressful yeah it was and we've
talked about that many times it was
it was weed versus booze yeah and that
was one where many fans and friends and
family who listen to the show message me
and said Jesus Christ man like are you
guys like okay like that was that was
like that was pers yeah but and but I
will promise you that it wasn't well
that one got I don't give a [__] what
you say about that was the worst
argument we ever had on the show and
that one well that's not true one thing
got cut out that was the worst thing
ever but uh but it was intense but that
one got personal in the sense of like
the criticisms of the other guy's team
were personal attacks on the weekends
yeah because that's because his
lifestyle it wasn't his food choice but
anyway but what I was saying this for is
because you just said sometimes it's
easier to roll yes and what I'm saying
is I'm just reiterating that if a button
of yours feels pushed like you know you
know what we're doing here of course
yeah of course that's why I say if you
believe that that's why I say it's
easier for you you're a guy that's
easier to roll there were a couple
things on the live stream where
I would I didn't say them but they were
just tossed at you and I remember
thinking oh if I was selling that just
happened to me I would have taken that
more personally oh oh wow okay like I
take things a little too personally
sometimes so it was like actually a good
example yeah so anyway so anyway we got
a little we gotta it wasn't anything
crazy it was just a little it was enough
that my gears were grinding we did it we
did like an extra salty or something
like that yeah yeah and I and I was just
like I was like all right and I just
wasn't in the best mood I wasn't mad at
you but I just was like kind of like ah
Christ
and I was in a bad mood that day that
day I just wasn't in a great mood and
then I was about to leave and I was and
V was like
I need you to sign the 250 posters for
the live stream which I would never
resent
getting it's a it's a privilege I mean
that that there's even the opportunity
to do something like that and anybody
even wants the stuff to begin with of
course but in that moment I was like
[__] and I was so hungry and I
just I was in a bad mood I wanted to go
home and then V started going
come on Joe it's gonna be so great like
try to cheer me up and then that was
making me go go further down into the
mood I was in and I was like I wasn't
mad at UV encouragement is yours is your
Kryptonite I was like I don't want to
hear this right now
I was just complaining to my manager
about something on the phone and he's
like he's like
and I said something about my apartment
I was complaining about something and I
go and then [__] and I said how much I
pay him rent and he goes well hey dude
how do I get a rate that good and I was
like dude I will drive to where you are
right now I was like I was like I just
when I'm in him I will walk five blocks
to my parking garage
wait an hour to get my car wait an hour
I will pay them and I will drive to you
and then I will go back five blocks I
will park and I will walk back five
blocks and then I have to go real quick
because it closes early
so you you get to me like I gotta make
this quick yeah
should I go in the other room
and I'm signing the posters and
at first I think I because I'm dumb and
my math sucks I was like I only have to
sign 125 because I was thinking half and
I was like
and then it has episode I was like no
wait
250. and then they that there were like
three times when I was selling those the
pile just wasn't going down yeah and I I
swear to God there a couple times I was
sitting there by myself and I went like
this
uh you've got to be kidding me like
because the pile just wasn't going down
and finally I got done I put them all in
a box I'm like okay okay I gotta go I
gotta go I gotta get
it and I was walking out
and I swear to God as I am
approaching the door out there I am
passing the door of the studio and I
hear the stuff it'll go practice poverty
that's what I want to do because I I
almost cry when I walk in my house so
ride the subway whatever I heard it in
real time like from him saying it to you
to my entrance I did not it was it was
it was an intervention from God really I
didn't stand there like and wait like I
heard that speech in it was in perfect
sync with me walking around the corner
where I could hear it to the moment I
entered I heard everything I needed to
hear and I was just like we'll play from
the beginning we'll play it from the
beginning
so so this is we'll just play for you
guys so you'll see it on on YouTube and
not hear it right okay you're gonna
start to try to practice poverty once or
twice a month what I mean by that is not
going crazy living on the street instead
of driving in because I have the luxury
of doing that in parking take the ferry
take the two buses sit coach flying to
you know a city
um um just to help appreciate because
then
you know you were here
get big
did you just say you're gonna practice
poverty if I fly coach and ride the
subway
you just described my records
he said he said that's one level
dude I gotta see it again because the
the [__] Undertaker gong right on the
door opening is the funniest thing I've
ever seen in my life shout out to pimpy
because then when I get
[Laughter]
I guess you know you were here
get big
did you just say you were practiced
poverty my flight coach and ride the
subway
you just described my regular life
Joe it's a good bit buddy huh it's a
good bit
it's a good bit Yeah Yeah
I mean I know you have to be in the
moment but that's that's a good like
that's my favorite part you're you're
you're like strained voice that's one
level above homelessness
here's here's the beauty of the here's
the beauty of cathartically what that
did for me though
as I was sitting in solitude signing
those posters I was going I was in my I
was in my head I was going through
everything that's happened in the last
month I started thinking about the
burglary like everything and I'm like
I swear to God my life and I was just I
was kidding so and I started getting in
that shitty place where you started
feeling sorry for yourself and you're
going
nobody likes me and you know what I mean
I started doing all that and I started
walking out and I heard Chris literally
describing my life as poverty and I
started laughing
did I open the door and then you started
laughing
everybody's laughing and then I sure
laughing and I was like
and I know it was good I was coming in
to be funny but I was but once everybody
started laughing it was like everything
like that like
from the moment that that I got a little
cross on our show to to whatever like it
all washed away and I was just like
I walked home in the sun after I was in
a great mood you know you
turned it around you had a mic he had a
great ending yeah you finished strong
yeah yeah yeah yeah it was a good quote
so so today
I'm sitting home and uh uh
my phone buzzes I look and it's Aaron
Berg okay
and he's like I just see the preview of
the text right and he says uh I can't
see the whole thing and it says
it says hey buddy my wife and I are
living on our savings right now because
I'm out of work
that's all I can see in the text and I'm
like well I go you don't want to say
that on this no no okay
I got it
my first son I go is berg sending out
one of these like
I hope I ask for money like can you send
money
and I'm like oh Jesus what's going on
and I open it and he goes dad said I'm
still happy to try to help
and I was like what and then he goes
you're not homeless and I go uh
what you're talking about I go I think
your phone got hacked and he goes no
what Chris said about you was terrible
you're not um I want you to know I'm
here for you even though I don't have
much and I did I was laughing so hard it
was so funny that's so funny it was so
funny man it was so people are loving it
all online it's just a great because you
can't
that just happens by chance you know
yeah that was so spontaneous that was
arguably no I don't say this because
that was that was one of the best no
pressure moments I was gonna say that
might be my favorite no pressure because
I felt like it I felt like it captured
the dynamic of the three of us like so
perfectly like it was like Chris
Chris does a thing where like he talks
earnestly and then he'll immediately be
like oh my God I'm a pig you know what I
mean
you like laughing like and like you're
laughter and like and like like and all
that like me being negative to Chris and
being like you're an animal like I just
felt like it captured the personality so
much everyone
perfect like finite moment and I was
like uh it was just it was just so
organic and fun it was great
it was great um so yeah so that's that
uh well we do have to talk about
last night
was the first ever taste buds live
stream yes
um if you saw it you know what how it
was yeah um if you didn't uh I'll say ex
it was more fun than I could have
imagined I agree it was a little over
two hours
um
I guess from people still shots and some
little like one second little things
people will see so
we could tell them what it was right I
mean well I don't think I don't think we
should I don't think we should say what
what it was okay yeah I think like let's
like let people
get the episode well here's the thing we
should ever publicly discuss what it was
or what happened okay I think it should
always the events of it should remain
within the people I agree or that have
so graciously paid to watch it uh no I
agree about that I mean I'm just talking
about like the obvious things that
people are gonna see well I was
obviously I was dressed like Ronald
McDonald the whole time because that was
finally we fulfilled the pun you know we
never even called out why I did that it
was the punishment fulfillment I think I
may oh no we didn't because I don't
think we ever mentioned yeah yeah yeah
well I mean because it works either way
because that that is just the person
that you want to be like that's your
idol yeah yeah
was modeled Rick Donald Donald
rickmonald is your idol Donald Rick
models yeah I mean yeah so so Joe
the full episode was dressed in a 100
authentic real professional uh yes
Ronald
Donald McDonald outfit I mean it's funny
man I'm I'm like seeing these I mean I
saw pics last night
like
you know like as we were doing the show
like pimp was putting picks up and I
could so I I saw a little bit of myself
this is the first time I'm really
concentrated
[__] the costume dude by the way major
shout outs to V for the makeup I mean
look you hit a grant you looked like him
like crazy you you look like him
something about your entire your gate
your body your face everything you if
you look like the real him
that's why it was so amazing what if I
got hired by McDonald's to be the next
one I mean dude you you look like him
and if you think it's funny when Joe
loses stop you have to see when he loses
his top dress as a full-on famous clown
there was there were there were four
other special guests as well oh five
other special guests I think five other
special guests as well yeah five
um I'm not We're not gonna say what the
battle was
I mean look we can't control the
audience if people reveal Secrets or
whatever we we hope that you don't
but if people do people do but we won't
do it but we won't say what the battle
was but the battle did end up being epic
it did end up in my opinion living up to
well the battle's on Twitter oh I'm
sorry I forgot about that okay well so
chocolate so the battle well let's say
this before you even say that because
it's a spoiler alert right if you
um if you didn't if you didn't see it
live last night there's only one other
way you can see it and it's just for the
next seven days you can buy a ticket it
might only be six by the way because
today's the first day I think it's six
remaining games well by the time this
comes out on Monday oh God yeah all
right five
so you have
you basically have two days oh geez okay
we should we should we'll do a we'll do
a a post on socials but if you're
hearing this there's two more days yeah
it's as of Wednesday it uh it gets taken
down from video on demand so if you
didn't see it yet and you still want to
see it
um you can go to moments the same thing
moments.com oh sorry dot Co moment
m-o-m-e-n-t dot co.com Co
moment.com taste buds you can buy
I took it to see it or whatever you can
buy it just stream it for yourself dream
it yourself it's 10 bucks I will say it
was the funniest thing we've ever
recorded for this network oh that was
nuts oh great I I do it was it was two
over two hours of straight laughs yeah
it was some fun surprise it felt like
freaking Pee-wee's Playhouse
it felt like it felt like it literally
felt like backstage at The Muppet Show
oh he's a perfect guest we gotta book
him oh that would be awesome I I reached
out to him about the Impractical Jokers
wow that would be but most of those I
got soft pitched a one-man show he might
be making the rounds
as Peewee again oh no [__] I would love
nothing more I've seen him on Broadway
as Peewee too I'd love it Mom anyway
yeah you you'll it's I think it's like
10 bucks and you get you'll get to see
it for the next two days uh look I'm not
just saying this pimp just said it it
was if you're a fan of this show I I I
wouldn't miss it if I was you it was so
ridiculous and so much fun and the
reason I also mentioned is because if
you want the full experience and you
don't want to know what the battle was
don't look at online or especially don't
look at the poll results so you can you
know enjoy it in real time and not know
you know that's all I was gonna say but
it was
it was all hands on deck everybody
everybody at no pressure and all of our
guests delivered huge
um it was a lot of efforts put together
and it just just went off amazing it was
just like yeah it was so fun and we we
just like were like it'll probably be
about two hours and we had a little run
of show that we were like Loosely basing
it on and it literally netted out yeah
took two hours and like five ten minutes
or something like that yeah I think uh
no I went over it went over great shout
out uh and thanks to pimp and Venetia
for uh all the hard work home runs and
and running everything you know
airtight airtight well-oiled machine as
they call it we put that shout outs to
all the guests that came through we'll
put the actual clickable moment Link in
the body of the YouTube ad uh and and
shout outs
you know last but certainly not least to
all the fans that watched
uh and and to the fans that weren't able
to watch like you're still supporters of
the show and and we appreciate all of
you so uh thank you thank you guys for
getting us and gals and they and
everybody for getting us to this point
of uh
being able to even do something like
this it was a ton of fun crazy and I
will say I'm glad I know initially we
were going to do it live in front of an
audience and then we decided to contain
it because we didn't want it to play
differently than the regular episode and
we had a lot of moving Parts among other
reasons and I actually in hindsight now
I'm glad that we didn't do it live
because uh it's just two different shows
so you know we would next time we're
going to do it live we'll gear our minds
toward live but I think this played
perfectly insulated here with this cast
of characters I agree this was a good
first outing I don't think I'll ever
unsee the Ronald McDonald makeup on how
do you feel after do you feel different
do you do McDonald's differently it's
great
uh
all the time that's not true I was not I
was very still until the very end you've
been so the very end yeah yeah you you
became you you came The Entity
that
that you've longed for your entire life
I don't know why that's that's not quite
this was like Kafka there was a
it was a full-on metamorph here
that's not resonating with me as much as
it is with you I saw you come out of
your cocoon being like
it's not like being uh it's not like if
you love Batman getting to be Batman
no it's food I think
I think you're more like hey dude you
you now own a McDonald's and you are
allowed all the free McDonald's I think
that would be a little more like a
fulfillment of my life's work but you
you became the king of that yes yeah and
it and it's wearing the authentic
costume the authentic is wild yeah the
authentic was wild that's the part that
makes it special and the fact that V was
able to do the makeup so accurately uh
like it was crazy it was pretty pretty
crazy so like you after was like you
know just getting all annoyed that you
couldn't get it off yeah that part kind
of sucked like you couldn't like it was
really hard to get it off it took a lot
I went home I showered last night and
then I showered again this morning and
I watched I thoroughly both times washed
my face because I felt like even in the
shower last night I was still catching
like little pieces the the outfit also
fit you like we got a tailor
it did really fit well I mean it's got
to be some kind of one-size-fits all
right your size I guess so it looked not
baggy not tight it literally looked like
it was tailored to you
this part this part was I think I think
we missed out on going out on the street
like that
I would have liked to see you on the
streets uh I mean yeah it's it's
possible uh you know I I I I will say
like
I thought about that because originally
what we were gonna do we can talk about
it now
because I don't know that I ever want to
put that makeup on again but uh
we were going to make the punishment it
was going to just be a video package I
wasn't going to be in that for the show
we were going to do a video package
where Sal and I were at Joey roses yeah
so I was going to be in there just kind
of as a customer hanging out pip was
going to be getting footage of that and
then I was going to enter as a surprise
bartender in the Ronald McDonald outfit
yeah did we say we might have said that
on the Pod yeah oh okay so but it would
have been end up doing that but I got to
tell you after I was in all of it last
night the idea of being in public it was
it was almost like giving me like some
anxiety really yeah because dude like
there was such
there was such like any time I was
getting an itch or whatever like and
like it's just bad I was like I'm gonna
mess the makeup up and then like when
you sat like you could feel it pulling
and then also to the level like kind of
itchy like I there was just something
about it where I was like I didn't I
didn't want to touch anything with the
gloves because I was afraid like I was
gonna like stain them or like like I
didn't want to touch the pizza for
instance like it was just a lot to think
about and I was like I it was hard
enough being comfortable just in our own
space well let me let me genuinely Pat
you on the back because I couldn't tell
and despite all that I will tell you
you were so so funny
you too man thank you I'm telling dude
you were so funny like whatever Groove
you got into
you perfectly married
the battle the costume the energy like
even the anger when you blew up like
every single note was played perfectly
like it was really really [__] funny
dude their experience yeah you too I
thought it was I thought you were great
not just I'm not just lobbing the ball
back yeah uh I thought I thought last
night that's what I was going to say
earlier about the Battle
being epic like I felt like last night
was a battle
because there are still people out there
that think like oh you guys you guys
turn it up for the battle it's like we
don't like we have plenty of very calm
battles it's there it's there yeah and
if it goes if it gets hot it's hot like
we're passionate and last night we
didn't know it was gonna get hot we even
said that I was I was concerned it
wouldn't and people would be let down if
it didn't but uh but um I felt like we
just hit you were hitting all the right
notes I was like this is this is the
show man this is like I was like this is
why we do the show this I was like this
is the groove of Chips Ahoy versus Oreos
all over again this is where it all
started what's really funny is that in
um in less than a week we're going on a
little like time out yeah like a little
a couple days away and we're going to
the place where we conceived the show
yes yeah because we had we're going to
the place where we had the morning
argument yeah of the best bagel yeah
we've had the arguments before we had
him on the crew but I think but I don't
know the cruise was chips away yeah yeah
Oreos and then when the house was very
legitimately the best bagel which was
episode two yeah and in the middle of
that we kept saying this is like we were
sitting on the couch I remember
there's a moment that happened uh on
that trip that is the is the only moment
I'm
concerned about reliving on this trip
uh concerned about really meaning like
focused on like like I'm like as long as
this moment happens that's all I care
about Oh I thought you're trying to
avoid it okay no no no no no no no no no
no meaning like that I want to okay that
I need to react which will rehab but we
were sitting
we had the argument we drug everybody in
the house into it it sounds like
everybody yeah we drugged everybody
dragged everybody in the house into it
um we we everybody was passionate it was
like we kept saying like this is like
when we were on the ship and we argued
the cookies then you said is this a
podcast and we started talking about
podcasts and the idea of this being a
podcast and we've told the story before
but anyway we were sitting on the two
couches talking to each other and we
were trying to think of a name I
remember this it was 10 8 it was 10
o'clock in the morning yeah we were
trying to think of a name and we were
going back and forth we're sitting there
and you go
this is like right after I not that long
after I'd moved home from LA because it
was still covered locked down it was
like our this is one of this is our
lockdown group that we made uh we're
sitting there going back and forth about
names for the show and you go you go
not to cut you off but shouldn't we be
doing this in the pool with a nice cold
beer yeah dude my face like like
illuminated and we just started laughing
at how good the idea was and we stood up
and you hugged me and you said don't
ever move to California ever again
really yeah and I said okay and we went
to the pool and drank beer in the pool
all day and then at 4 pm I remember
being like
it was right in front of us it was
because before that we we had like 20
names but it was food fight I think it
was going to be yeah yeah that was the
first one and there was 8 000 podcasts
called food fighting or whatever like
you know we thought we were like that's
it
that's what it is it's perfect it's
perfect yeah and then when you pull
these up bimby sometimes he pulls up
pictures and if we we you know we we
bounce off them is that that's just yeah
that's Photoshop right I'm just trolling
you guys oh you told me okay because
what about the what about the Cheez-It
Klondike Bar was that a troll I just
thought that was a good one
how are you finding this
it's like good accounts okay by hand to
God stay on this for a second my hand to
God
black Crescent
they don't have it anymore it was a
limited time menu item black Crescent
the bar across from Joey roses
on the corner yeah which has become one
of my favorite bars in New York City
because I started going to it when I was
I would need a break from when I was at
my bar yeah
yeah right
alternate bar where we were building
across the street too yeah yeah like you
didn't change the scenery much but we
were building out Joey roses I would go
you went to a stool 300 feet away I
would have to sit in Joey roses with the
contractors while they were like
literally building it and I was like
and after a while he'd be like this
sucks man and I'm like there's got to be
a bar around here so then black Crusher
was there and uh it and I've become dear
friends with Reynolds the owners and
they're they're awesome it's my favorite
one of my favorite bars in the world my
hand to God it was a limited menu item
they had Cheez-Its they made themselves
that were that big they were they had
Cheez-Its that were the size of the
Klondike crackers they made them
themselves and you got a basket of them
for like six bucks and he served them
with this dip dude they were on real
okay questions unreal did they taste and
have the consistency of a Cheez-It they
tasted exactly like picture this picture
of cheese at flavor same taste all right
Sophia Petrillo all right picture the
cheese and flavor except
warmer because it just came out of it
oven fresh baked flavor fresh baked
and just
it wasn't like crunchy cracker it was
like
it was like just a little bit softer but
still had a crunch to it okay like uh
like uh almost like graham cracker
consistently oh almost like a softer
graham cracker consistency but cheese it
dude it they were
they were so good they were talking
about the sauce
I can't remember what the sauce was but
the sauce was awesome and I remember
biting it and being like you don't need
sauce so this is great he was like just
try the sauce the sauce was almost like
an aioli or something sure would they
write on the menu homemade cheese it was
called like basketball
yeah and it was like I think he left out
the jumbo so then you ordered them and
the surprise was these giant jumbo why
don't you why do you get that why don't
you see if you can get that recipe from
them and we'll make them next week
Ah that's a great idea yeah that's a
great so I got it all right great idea
all right that's a great idea oh oh
no no um why don't we do that that's a
great idea I'll ask him yeah he might be
like you're competing uh bar with food
you think I'm gonna give you a recipe ah
get the [__] out of here I'll ask him
though I just feel like I'm going up I
want to cook I told my friend about
these you want to try and make them up
again I'll ask him I'll ask him I would
imagine he would give it to me the
recipe yeah we we would never make it at
my place anyway uh but uh but dude they
were uh oh that was so good but last
night V what was the things we didn't
use them last night we could talk about
them today because they were actual real
weird foods McDonald's Had
a pizza
well the McDonald's Pizza we discussed
but they had fries that had hot
chocolate sauce on them
exclusively and
[Music]
Japanese people would be crazy
they love their flavors because isn't is
it Japan that does those like 800
flavors of KitKat yeah that's right I
was telling you I saw and ate things in
Japan that I'll never encounter again
for the rest of my life until I go back
to Japan when did you go there I went to
Japan to do a show in Tokyo for about
extra just before lockdown
it was funny dude it was like it was
like an all it was almost like an ALT
show I was in like this bar called the
library and it looked like a little
library but it was it literally looked
like they plucked it out of Williamsburg
and put it in Tokyo but were there
because she was doing shows there too
Rachel uh
McAdams no no no no no but uh no the
girl from from [__] Westworld
that dated Marilyn Manson that meet the
girl that Evan Rachel even Rachel Wood
yeah Evan is her first name yeah okay
Rachel Evan wood Evan Rachel Wood is she
the one that says was she the one that
was famous famously in the in the
commercial this is your brain this is
your brain on drugs and she's still
trashing the kitchen
can you look that up I don't think so
ah Evan she was she was staying in the
apartment to the bar upstairs because
she was doing she does music
and she was doing music shows at the
same venue her partner who not like like
lover I just mean like her music partner
her guitar player he might have left uh
love who knows
uh he came down we're still in touch he
came down to my shop I met him because
he came and hung out of my shop wait
were you just doing
yeah I was just doing my own stance you
were doing the whole hour there wasn't a
showcase no I was just there doing it
obviously for expats then
it was crazy dude people came from like
some kid flew from South Korea to see
the show
and he got so drunk he walked on stage
during the show and got thrown out and I
felt I felt like sorry for him because
he was so excited to be there
but he he he was he was wrong he was out
of line wait how did you
they I like it booked yeah how did you
get booked in and how did you like so
these kids step out over there these
kids that produce shows in there's a
circuit over there okay there's a whole
Asian circus of comedy and and it's got
their America they're fans of American
Comedy and their audiences are fans of
America so they know Ari and I were
talking about trying to go over together
to try to do shows I know we I don't
think I'd come home alive from that
what's that flight like
I mean it's long but it's not bad
um I don't remember how long it is but I
got these kids kids you know they're
they're producers whatever they reached
out to me from China
and they said uh we want to get you into
China and we can get you into Tokyo too
and I said I I'm dying to go to Tokyo
and I'm and I would love to come back to
China I was already in China but I want
to come back so I went over I did Hong
Kong Shanghai
uh and then I went to Tokyo we got to
get you to church it was wild where are
we at right now just so I understand
we're at 40. okay great but I do have a
question did any of your like biggest
bits fall flat over there was there any
like no dude every show was amazing they
were so [__] I got you did all your
anime stuff
you know my anime stuff Ultraman all the
Ultraman material Power Rangers uh no
but the uh it's funny man they were I
did I had a thing about sushi I had a
thing in my act at the time about drugs
and
I had a joke about cocaine in it and the
audience at one of the shows they were
laughing but they were like
because like it's it's serious over
there dude like the one of the clubs I
played got shut down by the government
because of like speech like control or
whatever not because of me wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
meaning like you you can't say cocaine
oh dude they were like watch it like
you'll get like what's it what's it
what's it illegal to say
well China this is China this wasn't
Japan China is ex you're extraordinarily
monitored in China there's there's very
little personal freedom there's also
zero crime
because of that but um you you uh like
like for instance I think I'd rather run
the risk of getting shipped and say the
word cocaine all I want that's what I
say but do you have like one app there
there's one social app there I forget
what it was called but that app was like
it was Rideshare texting social media
like it's like a government approved app
and everybody was telling when I got
there they're like you got to use proxy
servers I never at the time I didn't
know what a proxy server was now like
VPN and all that stuff like they're all
out there but they were like you better
use a proxy server while you're here and
I was like why and they're like well
if you want to masturbate for instance
when you go back to your hotel later and
you want to watch porn you can't do it
through our servers like it's illegal I
love it that's the number one reason you
know and they were like also they're
monitoring everything you're doing so I
love that who said that to you first
like dude you got your proxy server just
later on you're gonna you're gonna get
to me frequently it was said to me every
guy's like did you get the proxies not
even kidding dude it was said to me and
but here's the it was an insane trip I
had one of the best times of my life but
here's this was crazy dude
we're in Shanghai and we were we did a
few shows in Shanghai but one of the
shows we were in like Shanghai like prop
or Shanghai where it was like it looks
like San Francisco it looks like a
western City like but it's like the main
Hub area of Shanghai and um guys this
podcast is brought to you by better help
I'm going through this right now it's
easy to get caught up in everyone else's
needs I just really feel like I'm in the
rat race sometimes and it's important to
take out a moment for yourself I try to
practice that
um because when we exert all of our
energy on others it could leave us
feeling burnt out for sure uh if you've
never tried therapy that's one of the
tools that can help you balance your
life so you can keep supporting all this
but also support yourself uh Joe is a
big champion of betterhelp uh he uses it
uh often
uh if you watch this pod you know he
sings its Praises all the time if I
always say if you if you're thinking
about therapy I think the hardest part
about therapy is just like people
there's some barrier to entry and so if
you're thinking about it this is a real
easy way to do it it's all online uh
give better help a try uh it's
convenient it's flexible it's suited to
your schedule you fill out a little
questionnaire you get match with a
therapist you get switch therapists at
any time with no charge so if you're
thinking about it find more balanced
with better help visit betterhelp.com
taste buds today to get 10 off your
first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash taste buds
bespoke posts one of our faves actually
we spoke about bespoke post uh in last
week's episode without even reading an
ad uh Joe said he got a gold pen that he
loved and uh so bespoke post basically
is a subscription service where you fill
out your interests and things that you
like and they curate a special package
for you monthly and basically you pay a
certain amount but the box is worth
probably on 70 bucks you pay a fraction
of that and it's kind of a little
surprise gift that comes to you every
single month you go to a box of
awesome.com you take a quiz and those
answers help them curate it for you they
release new boxes every month across a
ton of different categories I've talked
about them before plenty of times I've
gotten make your own fresh mozzarella
kit I've gotten a weekend bag I've
gotten a knife uh I've got it's so so
many so many good things uh plus this is
the coolest part with each box of
awesome you're supporting small
businesses because ninety percent of
everything that comes in your box of
awesome is from a small and upcoming
brand it's free to sign up you can
cancel or skip any time get 20 off your
first monthly box when you sign up at
boxofawesome.com and enter the code
taste buds at checkout that's box of
awesome.com code tastebuds for 20 off
your first box box of awesome.com code
taste buds
we did a show it was awesome
it was great after the show I'm drinking
with everybody
they're like
dude we want to take you to this to this
awesome like punk rock dive bar
we're gonna go we're gonna walk to it
it's like a quarter mile from here we're
gonna walk to like okay
we go to this place
we walk through like almost like what
looked like Woods for a minute and we
come into this opening and this bar is
just sitting there like an oasis and we
go in through the woods not not Woods
woods but like we want it was weird how
it was situated you passed the tree like
what do you mean it literally looked
like you were like walking through
somebody's backyard or something and
then all of a sudden there was this bar
there it was very weird right and we go
inside and sure enough it's like East
Coast punk rock
I'm like this is awesome I meet the
owner are you ready for this he's from
Philly come on dude he's we've got
mutual friends he knew the bands I used
to run around Philly with when I played
in dance that's that's crazy that is
crazy insane yeah so I was talking to
him about when when like when we should
do salsa windfall in Philly right and I
go shout out salsa shout out salsa
windfall and I uh big by the way huge
salsa windfall announcement coming soon
really huge yes I'm not kidding very
soon very soon you've got to promote
your uh Penthouse Letters oh yeah I'll
plug that at the end okay thank you
maybe salsa windfall plays the next live
stream
big big news coming big news coming
anyway so we so but but I'm like I'm
like so dude you like wait a minute you
know like kit from Wally and like I was
naming all these but he's like yeah dude
like remember [__] fod and I was like
what the [__] are you talking about like
it was crazy it's a mind-blowing thing
it was crazy man but but China and then
I went I thought you were leading into
something just now with what I thought
you
said something and you were like right
you were beginning a thought major
Charles windfall announcement coming
soon oh is that it
no I said the guy from Philly knew we
all knew all the same people that's it
there's no like story to it but like but
actually there is a story well no
there's not there's not a story but uh
we uh and then I went from there to
Tokyo
and Tokyo was was uh same thing like
there's just like people over there that
love American Comedy they're fans they
know they know who we all are
to different degrees but like the you
know these guys I would have rented a
car they adjust to drift
say I drifted in Tokyo I mean I think I
mean it's you know
and that's that's that's that's on God
um
but they're telling me like Neil Brennan
was just over there doing shows yeah
yeah he was filming a commercial or
something like that yeah do you want to
what do you want to do here
all right we got to get to this battle
we're we're spending a lot of time over
here uh I I know I'm curious to see how
many votes this actually gets but
Charles wanted to do this battle for a
long time I'm not trying to [__] on it
but but you but we can't say you curses
see how many votes it gets I just mean
no no I'm saying that because I'm
curious to see how much fans I'm curious
if anybody gives [__] about this battle
I mean it's a battle just like anything
else we've done we've done pool versus
ocean that that's got some we've done
fork for a spoon
yeah all right I mean it's it's a thing
I hear you it's a it is it is for me a
quintessential battle they're the only
two wait pet we gotta say what it is
it's pencil versus it's pencil versus
pen guys yeah they everybody uses them
everybody
across all that is true everybody does
use countries all ages all barriers okay
and they're the only two things really
do I mean unless you're dip in your pen
and some and and some in some Fountain
ink and doing calligraphy uh this is
what you use okay right everyone Stu I
mean come on and and and and and they
are each other's
all right they're each other's what
would I what would you call it yin and
yang yeah
yeah this is an X excellent excellent
they complete they complete one another
yeah for a non-food battle I think you
can't get a more perfect match-up than a
pen versus a pencil when there's only
two when only two things exist in a
space
I mean it's it's like it's it's like a
Thunderdome
well it depends on what that space is
can you can you write can I gotta write
something I don't want people to be like
ah erasable pen
because that's what they're gonna do
wait you can edit it after you put it up
all right write a comment I think you
can
no no no you can't you can't I don't
think you can you can you can edit after
it's posted 30 minutes
wow that's a new feature on Twitter
so Elon did do one or two good things
over there I thought you could
how do I do it
this is a first ever
update of the poll in real time on the
show all right just put just quote tweet
it
just quote tweet it erasable pen let's
go tweet it won't show up for the people
that look at it so I'm just going to put
it as the next response all right
erasable pen does not count
I I mean look
I uh will say as you do that I think the
one gray area uh we potentially didn't
consider how do you spell erasable erase
enable because it's not coming up as a
word just just just put pen with eraser
doesn't count or something
there was nothing worse than the
erasable pen when I was a kid we can
both agree on that yeah when I was a kid
I thought it was the coolest thing and
what you learn is it's [__] Inc yeah it
doesn't stick to the page it's terrible
uh I also think that we're people might
if artists
are gonna go
well there's colored there's there's a
there's a colored marker there's a
there's a brush there's a you know but
but I think what obviously we're talking
about here is is a writing utensil yeah
uh let's let's uh all right let's start
the battle uh it's time to be
b-a-t-t-l-e budge uh I am team pen
shallows team pencil uh there's not even
a contest here this is absurd that you
would even I have all the things I love
about the pencil and I have the things
that I
you know I'm gonna hit you I gotta just
I'm gonna hit you with the with an
argument ending right at the top Point
okay
a pen
you can give the gift of a pen have you
ever received absolutely a weighted pen
I've received both I got one in my bag
of awesome one time one of my one of my
or sorry my box of awesome I got a
weighted golden pen it sits perched on
my desk yeah it looks like the sort of
Excalibur you you you take it off and
you sign something with it you feel like
you feel like Scrooge yeah or or or or
Jimmy Stewart You Know It's a Wonderful
Life it feels so official it's
incredible I've gotten a pen as a gift
actually Q gave me a pen as a gift one
time uh and I've also gotten no joke for
a friend to give her again so much he's
giving me a pipe pen I'd be upset no it
was a
it was the one that he loves writing
with and we write so it was that nice it
was my go-to pen at that but I I I've
been giving a pen but I also have been
given a pencil and I don't mean the
traditional pencil it's just wonderful
really beautiful pencil and it's inside
like this sterling silver sheath and
it's got like a screw the the Eraser is
a screw that comes off and on the flip
side of that inside of it is a sharpener
and it's it's just it's beautiful I
actually got it from Comedy Central in
uh so then but then it sharpens down and
you're done or you could buy another
brand of that pencil and put it in there
or anything in the boxes any pencil but
this is it was an upscale I looked it up
the pencil was like upwards of 200 the
only thing and it's it's a wooden pencil
it's a wooden but it's in a sterling
silver you hold weight it's weight you
hold it in the sheath to right I mean
well the only thing that comes out is
the bottom I see what you're saying so
it's a pen it's a pencil trying to do
with the weighted pen No it's it's just
a it's just a pencil uh in an Innovative
pencil
well but that you put it your own pencil
nothing about it is a pen the only thing
that constitutes a pen is ink my friend
this had lead in an eraser but I'm
saying you you buy a number two pencil
and put it inside this case
no no it came with its own pencil from
that company so then you got you buy a
replaceable pencil and put it in yes
although you could put anything in there
I'll I should I'll bring it on what
happens when the pencil gets shorter and
it doesn't fit inside the case anymore
it does how it's the way it was the
mechanism that keeps pushing it forward
the way it was like toothpaste style
yeah it was the way it's a design and
I'll tell you another thing what are
those pencils what are they us uh Wings
pilot Wings what are they called the
wings they they're they're they're the
ones with that like broad like flat
eraser head top head
but just put like best pencils it'll
come up right away
just just scroll it's it's
where you going no not not on here not
on here
just go to just go to Google searches
Blackwing that's it the Black Wing that
pencil I I I I love them this is what I
see it's wonderful so they have a whole
host of pen a pencil and they have every
pencil rights feels and and writes
differently so you could have like one
that like writes fast one that writes
slow one that writes a little wider or
smoother one that writes very like it's
it's just a it's just a wonderful
company I really like it they sell um
replaceable eraser heads too so you
don't get stuck with that empty eraser
up top with half a pencil left like we
did all through our school years and
then you chew that that's a but let me
tell you something else that's something
I love I love when I had a number two
pencil in high school or grammar school
and it was like down to this and I lost
the Eraser and then I chewed it and I
chew on that little metal thing on the
end oh I love it I love biting into a
pencil and leaving teeth marks I always
I have personalized pencils I always put
messages on them I always hated pencils
because they always got depressing they
always marked up all your stuff in your
book bag I'd get like a pencil case babe
I got a brand your pencil case would
look like it went through a [__]
trash compactor by the end of the school
year I I hated pencils for their lack of
boundaries they just didn't know how to
keep to themselves ever ever once in a
while you get a pen that explodes sure
but but oh Joe Joe
what a pen explosion it's horrible is a
lifetime of lead markings inside your
bag it's hard explosion of the pocket
and this pocket on your hands you ain't
getting that okay
I can count on one hand how many times
it has happened one hand right so it's
happened at least five times that's
horrible no no I can count on one hand
how many times has happened meaning I I
can remember maybe two times whatever
it's still traumatic it is traumatic my
point is is with the pencil it was
always a problem it never stopped it's
all I don't know about that well this is
what I'm gonna this is what I see what
it says
the pen is David Letterman
it's no it is not hold on let me
famously use pencils let me finish let
me finish okay let me just say fine
Johnny Carson the pen is Johnny so you
just you don't know if it's Johnny
Carson well I would I I can I I think
that Johnny Carson David Letterman are
the two greatest okay late night hosts
of all time
I'm gonna go with Johnny Carson though
just to suit your your David Letterman
pencil thing
the pen is Johnny Carson
it's a professional
it rules the roost it knows it rules the
roost it comes out it's classy it
doesn't need to a pen is not classic
hold on a second let me let me finish it
is nothing it has nothing it has nothing
to prove
it knows what its job is it does the job
that's the end of the day I have a lot
to say yeah I look at pencils I see
colored pencils I see uh monogrammed
pencils I see pencils with custom
messages on them I see pencils with zany
pictures on them and when I say
versatility and what I see is Conan
O'Brien
someone who's good at his job but can't
turn it off tries way too hard all the
time 20
plus year late night veteran oh you go
Conan you're great at what you do
stop for a second I mean I stop learn
from the pen pulling the pencil for a
second pulling the pencil Conan O'Brien
is a compliment let me let me let me
talk a little bit okay yeah okay I love
biting a pencil I love the different
colors of pencils I love this thing this
thing when you do this and your pencil
looks bendy that's done with it
started with a pencil and it's meant to
be a pencil because a pencil by nature
is way longer than the pen so you do the
Bendy trick another thing I like about
the pencil you could I I like putting it
behind my ear you could do that with a
pen but you know carpenters and people
they put it behind the air that's fun
let me talk to you did you talk about
the giant novelty pen a pencil a giant
novelty pencil I used to get it Six
Flags no the giant novelty pencil set to
set the precedent okay
I love the fact that you are not married
to what you write you can erase it right
then and there it's called commitment
Sal there's nothing wrong you just said
you just said oh my God you can edit now
on Twitter what a great new feature
guess who [__] invented the edit bro
the number two pencil
the number two pencil came way before
white it's the OG it's the original
writing tool I also love the fact that
you can I love the active sharpening I
love it there's a skill to sharpening
it's fun I try to sharpen it and not
break it and do a whole little curved
little roll of what uh I loved white out
I felt like white out it showed that you
were Earth you were a man of discipline
that when you had to when you made you
you weren't going to make a mistake but
if you did to correct that mistake you
hit that had to be fine finally tuned
with the brush bro I like it bro you're
nuts right now bringing white out into
into this you're nuts because whiteout
is not for you it's a strike against you
you need a whole nother purchase a whole
other company a whole other business to
correct the mistake that the pen causes
all the time because there ain't no
going back with the pen okay and you're
bringing up white out clumps up okay and
then everyone knows you put it on you
smell the fumes and then sometimes you
go too thick it comes up then you go to
right over it and it looks like you were
riding on a hard surface and your pen
goes all weird everyone knows when
you've used embarrassing I'm gonna hit
you with a Star Wars quote I'm gonna hit
you with a Star Wars quote a more
civilized oh sorry a far less clumsy
weapon for a more civilized age the pen
is the lightsaber it's for a more
civilized age it's for somebody that
says I know what I'm doing before my pen
hits the pace mistakes do happen and the
whiteout's there if it's needed it won't
be but it's there if it's needed a
pencil is the Blaster a pencil is for
some schwa's buckling uh loosey-goosey
Han Solo type that wants to run around
getting into swindles and Scandals
shooting his way out of his Pros Han
Solo you love him more than Luke
Skywalker and you love Luke Skywalker
solo okay let's talk about the negative
parts of the pen okay what about when
one is on the [__] Fritz even though
it has tons of ink and you got to keep
doing this [__] thing
lighter what about when to put a lighter
when the point breaks sharpen it oh and
when the new pencil and when the ink
doesn't do that that's annoying and then
and then and then a pencil will write on
and then you get shavings let me finish
yeah the pencil will write on any
surface you ever get a receipt that you
have to sign for a pen with a pen
you cannot sign a receipt with a pencil
how dare you how deep are you right on
anything no I've had enough of going to
use a pen and it not working and I'm
about to shake it violently and then
sometimes there are materials like the
receipt that you have to sign that the
pen just won't [__] work on for
nothing and you know what I hate to you
talk about that it's so it's so Advanced
and it's civilized don't don't don't
dress up a [__] you know a dud in a
tuxedo okay because most pens are [__]
you buy a 12 pack of big pens for two
dollars and they that's what they're
really worth if you okay let me let me
just do this by the way by the way big
pen the the the the spine the
Cornerstone of the of every office
around the globe these guys locked down
pennies like nobody ever this is like I
can't even think of them McDonald's yeah
is it okay guess what guess what the Bic
pens uh plastic sheath is modeled after
the pencil okay it's not round and
smooth what they did was they took the
the hexagon shape of the octagon shape
of a pencil and they put the classic
pick that you just said was most picks
no the classic pick is the smooth white
tube Bic that's all that is the [__]
worst pen known to man those don't work
every other time you pick them up those
are terrible those are horrible sorry
they gave them those are horrible
they're sorry they gave you and the
globe an affordable writing tool that
cost two dollars a dozen what about so
so people could get on with their lives
and conduct business without being
pencils are way more affordable than
pens so [__] that you
that's an upscale pencil bro all right
don't play stupid about pencils okay but
don't play stupid about pens you're
gonna you're gonna you're gonna
I'm stupid bro I'm telling you
everything that's no good opinion yes
picking on it you're picking on a budget
a budget brand any [__] pen bro if
you don't have some type of expensive
pen every pen shits the bed pick every
pack as a mascot there is no mascot for
pencil by the way can you even name a
brand for pencils I can't yes what
um
if you go to Target in the stationary
hour what's the brand of pencil yes I
know it I have them in my drawer Andrea
uh something uh something you know I
love a good legume and I find that the
protein carries through the day it's a
great quick snack I'm a sucker for
cashews I love a good uh uh pecan I mean
there's nothing better than nuts and
nuts.com
is your One-Stop shop for freshly
roasted nuts dried fruit even sweets
Pantry Staples like specialty flowers
and more their wide selection means
there's something for everyone they
offer gluten-free options organic
choices and other diet friendly products
uh whether you're looking for something
sweet or savory they got it all uh I
love them they sent a a box full of all
the like all different varieties to my
house
they're awesome I even love The Branding
um you could shop a la carte or opt into
a hassle-free auto delivery so you never
run out of your favorite items uh yeah
it's top quality too top priority they
roast their nuts and pop they're corn
the same day it ships so they reach you
deliciously fresh and I can account for
that since 1929 they've been doing it
the old-fashioned way right now nuts.com
is offering new customers a free gift
with purchase and free shipping on
orders of 29 bucks or more at nuts.com
taste buds so go check out all the
delicious options at nuts.com tastebuds
and you'll receive a free gift and free
shipping when you spend 29 or more
that's nuts.com taste buds guys I want
to talk to you about game time
um they're a newer sponsor to us and
they are awesome I'm seeing commercials
all over the place basically it is your
last minute stop for tickets to concerts
sporting events other events uh lowest
price guarantee they have event
cancellation production uh you can see
an image of the seats you wanna uh image
of the stage or whatever from the seat
you're in which is super helpful because
a lot of times you buy these things
blind and you don't realize it's further
away than you thought or there's an
obstructive view
anything in your area you could search
it's the place for last minute ticket
deals okay forget planning months in
advance game time has deals on tickets
right up to the day of the event Flash
Deals on football basketball baseball
concerts comedy theater everything
game tie guarantee the game time
guarantee means you'll always get the
best price so if you find tickets in the
same sectional Row for Less anywhere
they will credit you 110 so you get your
money back plus extra money
okay that's pretty cool it's the fastest
growing ticket app in the country
tickets are sent directly to your phone
you never have to dig through an email
um matter of seconds to do it two Taps
snag the tickets without the stress with
Game Time download the game time app
create an account use code taste buds
for twenty dollars off your first
purchase terms apply again just create
an account and redeem the code taste
buds for twenty dollars off download
game time today last minute tickets
lowest price guaranteed folks Joe DeRosa
here my new record
the penthouse papers collected readings
is dropping with a special thing records
on June 9th I had a two year long op-ed
column with Penthouse uh magazine and we
got all my columns together and I read
them into a microphone and from that
microphone to your ears how about that
folks it's a nice easy listen it's sort
of like an audio book I want you to
check it out I think you're going to
like it I'm really proud of the writing
I'm really proud of the pieces I was
proud of them when they ran in the
magazine I'm still proud of them and I
hope you enjoy them and that's why we
put this all together also if you're in
New York come to Joey Rose's open seven
days a week 11 30 a.m each morning open
into the night sandwiches available all
day long affordable drinks affordable
food always a good time Joey Rose's
nyc.com for detail and you can get that
album where digitally on any platform
you stream your music from and if you
want to buy it you can actually pay to
download it from one of those sites like
iTunes that'll charge you but anyway no
physical release just a digital thing
to lull you to sleep each night
what's up guys first things first the
Impractical Jokers cruise is happening
January 22nd to the 26 2024 we are
hosting it with Eric Andre uh there's
gonna be a ton of comics and bands and
DJs it's our fifth one you can get
tickets right now it's 65 sold out uh at
pre-sale so get tickets right now at get
ship faced cruise.com you could also
enter to win a free trip and practical
jokers are finishing out the first leg
of our tour now through July all uh
dates and tickets are available at
impracticaljokerslive.com in the coming
weeks we have Minneapolis Des Moines
Kansas City Nashville uh St Louis and
don't forget anything
that's it
the green uh uh something mitochondria
mitochondria what is it mitochondria
what is it called
to condorosa to condacondra even with it
being half ready you can't remember it
that's pathetic there's nothing to this
battle that I couldn't name
thank you it does nothing let me let me
what about this that inevitably happens
with every pen what about when the the
ink starts to Clump on the ballpoint and
it just stays there like a clump
sometimes it gets dust to hair on it and
then when you go to right the clump
transfers to the page and the first the
first time you touch the page to write
something has a big blotch of ink in the
first letter I gotta tell you and then
you gotta like wipe it off unless you
wipe it off your dress unless you're MCS
you're doing a wonderful sketch uh
with amazing shading and stuff that's
going to hang in the museum you can
shove those pencils right up your ass
nobody gives a [__] nobody writes
utensil that's still around nobody cares
are so good yeah pencils wouldn't exist
go to the go to that go to the desk in a
bank pen no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no that's for legal
reasons not because they choose to do a
pen it's permanent ink and that's the
thing I that's the benefit of the pencil
you can adjust all you want the edit is
life my friend okay you are in a prison
with a pen you're in an ink filled
prison we live in
you have to cross out and you have to
cross out so good that they can't tell
what the original thing was and they
can't turn it around and look in the
light and see what the imprint was the
upside down
the astronaut pen an entire episode of
Seinfeld based around why are you not
when I when I say the negative the
things about the pen that they they
stole from the pencil shape that the ink
clunks
it clumps
the feather quill is the original pen
that was first that's pre pencil I got
news for you we're not talking feather
quilts but that's what depends we
literally said when we posted this that
calligraphy and dipping a feather
Patrick isn't counting you're look at me
what is that first one 2000 BC what is
that is that a is that a pen that's a
read pin number one 2000 BC uh 1600 A.D
came the feather quill which was in an
evolution of the Reed pin 1827 a day
comes
since you're saying the pencils first
let's see how it's convenient was the
pencil invented before 2000 BC
1795 you are in let me ask you a
question let me ask you a question let
me ask you a question embarrassment Joe
Joe stay focused and like let's have a
volley here because I have a lot to say
you keep ignoring everything I'm saying
I'm not you're saying nonsense I'm not
saying nonsense
if the pen was around for three thousand
and eight hundred years before the
pencil why the [__] was the pencil even
invented and needed why I don't know why
because the Pen's not doing it so it's
not cutting it babe because hold on hold
on hold on hold on yeah these are the
top two dogs in this fight there's
really no one else okay if the pen was
that good why was the pencil invented
and why do we continue to use the pencil
because it's an innovation past the pen
that allows you to edit it allows you to
write with a point that you feel
comfortable listen to me if you like a
medium point and a wide and a wider
letter that you you can you can sharpen
to that
I'm addicted to Sharp and you called it
shavings
paintings
I love electric electric shock how many
points you're gonna make well I'm gonna
be making I'm gonna make all my points
and you should let me finish them you
can't make all of them I cut you off
you're just cutting me off I'm not
you're talking for too long no I am not
I let you say what you had to say and
every time I'm making like a couple of
different points out yeah speaking of
the pencil I'm making great points okay
well now I can't remember what you said
that to report to any of it dude I gave
you five reasons the pen sucks and 20
reasons the pencil is great and you
didn't you just literally changed the
topic every time I said one of those
things I didn't change any topic you're
saying too many things in a row I'm
trying I'm sorry there's so many great
attributes respond to each one you're
not letting me and now I can't remember
any of it and then you're going you're
not responding Daniel you're not
pointing you're not
[Music]
yes you did I just said why was the
pencil why was the pencil even needed if
you've been around for 4 000 years why
didn't we just stick okay let me stick
that's the first point you made 200
points that's a stupid point here's why
that's like saying why was the Snickers
bar invented when you have pure fudge
pure fudges if pure fudge is so good why
would they make a lesser form of
chocolate that's an idiot Point what do
you mean you're saying my point okay
what you're saying benefits me you're
talking you're you're asking me a
question I'm answering but what you're
saying makes no logical sense it does
make logical sense just because a lesser
version of a thing was invented you said
it right there you just said it a lesser
version of a thing came out of his own
mouth the pencil I'm talking about is
the Lesser version why do we need a
lesser version
if we had the best version I just said
but say the real thing Joe because it's
an innovation and it allows you to erase
and it changed the game for writing it
changed the game before that people had
to just spill ink on the words they
didn't want you asked a question I'm
answering you're saying why would they
invent this thing when the other thing
existed yes it wasn't needed and you
give me a broad answer like that's so
stupid it's like the Snickers okay but
say why this is invented because that is
the reason it was invented it has I'll
tell you why it was invented because
society and this goes without fail
devolves as it goes along and people
need shortcuts the further and further
we get
how is it a short every single thing a
pencil is more work than a pen you have
to put in a little effort you gotta
sharpen it you have to erase the pencil
in my opinion the pencil has two
purposes two that is it number one uh
anything with mechanical drawing where
you have to be able to make
yeah that's what I just said go ahead
and art
oh the greatest thing on the planet but
but
but pens are used in art all the time
pens are not used for mechanical you're
right I love pen art
um
oh yeah I've never seen you've never
seen you've never seen paint pen art
you've never seen this terrific I love
it yeah it actually is amazing yeah it
is
you don't even know what the tactileness
of a pencil see that over there I love
the touch I love the tactiles of mental
it feels better in the hand it's organic
it's made of wood it's earthy I like
that they're in one pencil's lifespan
there are all different sizes sometimes
I love love writing with a fresh long
pencil because it gets smaller there you
go there you go I'm just going to call
them out every time he does it now so he
could [__] take a look in the mirror
I I will say that pencils are tied to
anxiety with tests in school no they're
not you need it for Scantron
yeah but that's not tied to anxiety it's
tied to education
I hate it yeah yeah school sucks
[__] nerd I mean it's apparent it's a
parent your education stopped at the
[__] ditch
okay well it was an awesome moment in
school by the way it was an awesome
moment in school when my pet when my
when my teacher said to us in the sixth
grade you're all getting older now and
we want you to start using pens it was a
sign of adulthood it was a sign of
maturing look at everybody nodding uh
how right I am if you think that uh
using a pen is a sign of adulthood you
are off you're a rocker you're off your
rocker that's something they told you to
make you feel that you had big boy pants
on Joe you could use a pen or a pencil a
pencil is a better writing utensil hands
down you had you could do anything the
pen can do plus change it all right and
you didn't let me finish you cut me off
I really love that there is an evolution
of a pencil you have a pencil lifespan
that you can feel it's tactile a pen
runs out of ink you don't know for one
thing you shake it big [__] deal
people lend you a pen that Cap's been
chewed on it smells it's disgusting I
don't like the shoes on the Eraser until
it falls off and then bites the metal
yeah you're right you're right because
I've never seen a pencil with teeth
marks in it I've never seen that because
p people constantly put the pencil in
their mouth while they think I don't
lend a pencil oh this is your answer you
don't lend a pet you're so funny I don't
lend the pencil you're right as you
ask Eric to being able to lend a pencil
he goes I don't lend a pencil all right
no no no so we gotta go to the phone I
also like I like the fact that there's a
three quartal and pencil then it becomes
a half pencil and then it's just so fun
the end of the pencil when it's like an
inch or two and you're writing with that
a little bit but that's my hand okay and
I I love the fact that I can keep
sharpening and I just [__] love it
yeah that I I love the Precision point
of a lead pencil perfectly sharpened
it's so satisfying it's like when you
open the peanut butter and the
smoothness is on top when you finish
sharpening a pencil perfectly it
literally feels good okay when you
sharpen one and you get that whole ridge
without a breaking it feels awesome and
fun I love an electric sharpener you cut
me off before I even love the old school
sharpener like this everything about a
pencil is beneficial and fun it really
is okay okay a pen
what do you got Joe what do you got you
didn't say anything about when it runs
out of ink and you have to shake it you
didn't say anything about it you ignored
it you didn't say anything about the
pieces of paper it will never write on
like those receipts you didn't say
people I've seen people I literally
and I didn't say anything and now you're
at least I'm responding to what you're
saying you didn't you cut me off and
moved along asking me to respond to you
after you just talked for three minutes
but don't say [__] back
of course you sign a receipt every day
but you know what I'm talking about
right the receipts that like are that
weird texture which is like half of them
and you have to like shake it and then
write on the back and scribble to make
the ink come out to coax it out okay and
then you go back are you done yet no I
have great points okay
just to be you talking and I'll just not
talk I had this I've seen people take a
lighter to the front of a pen to coax
the ink out I really have I really have
and by the way when you lose the cap a
pen is a [__] piece of [__] when it
doesn't have the cap on top to kind of
balance it and weigh it out and you
write with a pen without you if you'll
pick if your Bic loses a cap it sucks
are you talking that's right I'm talking
about and the weight of a pencil is
better I understand writing with a
pencil writing with a pencil I
understand now why you wanted to do this
you clearly have some sick
weird hang up with pencils and you had
to get all this out of your system
because God knows nobody else was going
to listen to this yes I mean this is a
tirade like I've never heard about what
are you in the Civil Rights pencil
organization this is [__] that
doesn't that doesn't exist and I don't
think I have any hang up about pencils I
think this is episode 140 of something
that we've battled trivially 139 times
before this so no problem okay the
tactileness of a pencil will beat a pen
any day the weight of a pencil every day
we have to go to the phones all right
and I will mention the multi-colored pen
that has all the different colors yeah
four colors buddy I have literally the
spectrum of colors I have hundreds and
hundreds of colors we also have hundreds
of colors of pens too no you know you
got about I don't carry a case of
colored pens around like a two-year-old
going to Art Classes
by the way do me a favor next time you
have a big important application to fill
out for a loan or or maybe a lease or
something like that legally cannot do it
in pencil and watch them yeah
move the application to the bottom of
the people you can't do it legally just
like just like you said you can't use a
pen if you're an architect legally a
winning tweet today without question the
pen is mightier than the sword the
pencil is literally enough fun that's a
that's a fun uh follow at booty time six
nine by the way at booty time six nine
that's that's our winner by the way the
pen is mighty and the sword is that
doesn't necessarily mean pen and
everyone knows that oh forgot it just
means no you know what it means it
doesn't mean it only says pin you're
gonna win it all he says I took this
battle on you're gonna win 90-10 easily
because everyone uses pens over pencils
but that doesn't change my opinion that
the pencil is superior to the pen
pimp let's just go right to the vote we
got a winner let's just go right to the
vote I want to just see what happens in
this vote I don't even I don't want to I
don't want any to think tipping us off
it's gonna be 90 10 pen I'm I've
accepted that when I accepted the battle
but I I still wanted to talk about all
the you've talked about it can I say
you've talked can I I'll say one last
thing I'll say one last thing I'll say
one last thing right stop now I'll say
one last thing I think that I made at
least at least a dozen points of the
cool attributes of the pencil and I
named it at least half a dozen if not
more of the downfalls of a pen you gave
none of that you said that's better
pencil's not as good you won't let me
tort and shut up and don't say a word
I'll report to every one of your points
right when the pencil gets smaller it
sucks it hurts your hand it makes your
hand cramp when the Eraser falls out it
sucks and the Eraser gets dirty and
useless before it falls out chewing on
the metal thing hurts your teeth it's
like chewing on tin foil pencils people
put them in their mouth they have teeth
marks in them it's disgusting the point
breaks all the time it's a pain in the
ass you can't do anything important
important or legal or whatever with a
pencil a pencil if you don't a pencil
has to be sharpened constantly which is
a pain if you have a pencil and you
don't have a sharpener it's useless the
point breaks all the time it's terrible
pencils suck all the time unless it is
for two specific things sketching or
doing mechanical drawing and by the way
with mechanical drawing they're using
mechanical pencils which I don't think
even count with all the arguments you've
made that's a completely different
device but whatever a pen
you almost always is not a problem when
it is I don't care if I have to shake it
that doesn't bother me it takes two
seconds nine times out of ten when I'm
trying to sign a receipt or whatever
you're talking about I don't have a
problem and a pen is more reliable a pen
exploding once every 10 years in my bag
is far less a pencil will never happen a
problem to me then the mess and a
headache of a pencil pencil A pencil's
never made anyone lose their [__] I rest
my pencils never made anyone lose their
button-down shirt their [__] leather
bag I got it just explore all right
let's go to the vote let's go ink on
your hands like you robbed the [__]
bank and the bag exploded let's go to
the vote everything you just said there
every single thing every single thing
you there everything I had and had an
answer for every single thing you said
okay okay all right what happens when
you get a pen in your hand can we please
just go to go to the what happens when
you get it basically I don't want to
talk about this anymore
don't want to talk about this anymore
this is psychology terrible points this
is psychotic I think this is your worst
ever defense of a knife okay
way better than I thought way better
than I thought 76.5 to 23.5 that's more
than double what I thought it was guess
what that's right I still love you buddy
I love you too
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to them